what was it like to be but you're acting
hat back on for a minute and be a part
of such a historical piece of cinema it
was really special you know I've always
wanted to work with Roland and the fact
that was this story one that I think was
really important that was told under the
direction of someone who had a real care
for this for this project and wanted
everyone involved to care as much as he
did you know it was great and and I was
honored to be a part of it to get to be
a part of telling this story that I'm
not sure a lot of people know about and
so putting a spotlight on something like
this is really special now this is your
second second acting for a as a pilot
are you trying to tell us something like
are you Tom cruising Harrison fording
this is a pilot next on the list I'm not
in Top Gun so unfortunately I missed
that one well yeah I mean I don't know
why I keep getting cast as a pilot I
don't to be stereotyped as the pilot guy
but worked out Tom it's it and then he
ventured out so who knows
now all night long we've been asking
every one of the greatest transformation
in this movie and there's two votes and
I would like you to vote Mandy just
voted for you is it a Nick Jonas is
mustache or be Woody Harrelson's hair oh
I'm gonna go with my mustache yeah it
was very French little Pepe LePew by
those my inspo and it did need some
darkening I'll just say that what a
brown could think of a mustache I hate
she liked it her father had one and so
it was sort of like she was into it and
then I said I'm taking this off the
minute I wrap and then she was like you
know I realize I don't like this as much
as I thought I did and the Christmas
music Christmas me yeah comes out very
Christmas Merry Christmas a little early
but it's coming Friday it's basically a
song that we fell in love with that was
written by the same writers producers
that we use on all our music you know
that were releasing now so it has that
touch where it feels current modern and
still has that classic edge exactly it
sounds great
[Music]